where we left off in the last video the
North had just won the Civil War
unfortunately for Abraham Lincoln it was
two months after he was assassinated but
now the North was dominant and
essentially occupied the south and we
enter a period called reconstruction and
reconstruction can refer to one of two
things and they're somewhat related one
is just the reconstruction from the war
obviously there was a lot of damage done
on both sides but it's usually referred
to the actual reconstruction of the
south and to some degree kind of the
reform of the south and I'm going to
glaze over a lot of details like I did
in the last video and I might ignore
some major events that you might find
important and I'll get back to them
don't worry but the three big things
that happen during reconstruction other
than the fact of the the north occupying
the south and essentially to a large
degree suspending democracy in the south
and installing its own politicians it's
it's own lawmakers is that the United
States passed the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments these are known as the
reconstruction the Reconstruction
Amendments in 1865 you have the 13th
amendment and this abolished slavery so
let me write this here this ended ended
slavery we talked about the Emancipation
Proclamation and that was essentially
Abraham Lincoln's executive order this
was the speech he made but now it became
official law in 1865 then in 1868 you
have the 14th the 14th amendment which
made everyone every every person born in
the United States a citizen and this
includes the freed slave so it's kind of
like the slaves are now free and they
are also citizens and then in 18 in 1870
you have the 15th amendment which gave
all free men the right to vote and
obviously now all men were free there
were no non free men so the right to
vote and I emphasize the men because
even at this point women did not have
the right to vote the right to vote and
the 14th amendment also introduced a due
process which I won't go into the
details here but it essentially said
look the government the government has
to go under a due process or essentially
it has it's it's subject to its own laws
when determining whether it can kind of
take away property from or or in some
way in
I guess in some ways infringe on rights
of other people but we'll talk we'll
probably do a whole video on that in the
future but these were the real take away
so it really brought the former slaves
at least by law by these amendments on
equal standing but we know that in
practice that didn't happen and you go
fast-forward to 1877 and you essentially
have the the reconstruction period
formally ending the occupation of the
south formally ends and as soon as the
occupation of the south formally ends
you essentially and democracy comes
about you have a bunch of people coming
to power and at this point of time the
Republicans were essentially you know
the north and these were the people who
are a kind of anti-slavery you know
Abraham Lincoln was a Republican and the
Democrats come to power in the south and
we can talk about how the the different
perceptions of the different parties
change over time but at this point as
soon as the occupation ended and to a
large degree and you know I'd put
democracy in quotes because even in this
period the the North had essentially not
occupied anymore but the the elections
you know these were things that were
heavily contested you had both sides of
them kind of exerting force and in
particular you have the Jim Crow laws
being passed in the south and they're
called Jim Crow based on this parody in
the early 1800s it was a practice for us
but you know but I would say white men
in the south at this time or even well
before this in order to parody blacks
they would paint their face black and
they they would act silly in all of this
and Jim Crow was the name of one of
these characters that was portrayed in
the early 1800s I think it was jumpin
Jim Crow was the name and so that's
where the laws come from but the Jim
Crow law is essentially segregated
blacks and whites in the south and even
though the idea might have been that
they were equal the reality were that
the conditions for blacks the places
that they were separated to were far and
feared that to use separate drinking
fountains they had to use separate
bathrooms they had to they couldn't sit
in the same parts of theatres or in the
same parts of buses and these lasted all
the way until the civil rights movement
all the way to the 1960s now at the same
time
that all of this was happening you kind
of had this post war this post-civil war
boom in the economy where you had this
kind of massive building of the
railroads and steam engines and you kind
of this you know to some degree it was
the the first well I don't want to say
the first there was kind of many there's
kind of many ages of mass innovation but
all of these things tend to always lead
to a little bit of a bubble and then in
1873 what you have happening is a lot of
the governments of the world start going
off of the gold and silver standard and
they go to the gold standard and what
that happens is is that anyone who's
left on the silver standard or partially
both the gold and silver stat standard
their currency would devalue and back
then it was viewed as an unambiguous
negative for your currency to devalue we
can later talk about that there's more
nuance there and so the United States
decided to follow suit and actually the
big the big actor here was was was
Germany that decided to go off of the
silver standard and go on a pure gold
standard and so the United States
decided to follow suit with the coinage
act in 1873 but this leads to this huge
they call it the panic of 1873 there's a
couple of things here one it completely
demolishes the price of silver although
this was already happening on a global
basis it hurts the silver miners and the
industries associated with the silver
miners but I guess more importantly you
now this restricts the money supply and
I won't go into all of the economics of
it when you restrict the money supply
you essentially increase interest rates
and it essentially popped the bubble
that was forming due to the railroads
and all of the booming business and then
you essentially had the United States
entering a depression and that
depression lasts from 80 until eight
from 1873 when the coinage Act and kind
of this bubble burst all the way to 1879
but lucky for the United States after
that time period after it recovered from
the depression it actually recovered it
like this super fast rate and this was
one of the fastest economic growths in
US history you had this huge you had
this huge influx of immigrants of
immigrants tens of millions from Europe
and by 1890 the United States was now
the richest country in the world on a
per capita basis which is amazing
because only a hundred years ago
was kind of this colony of Great Britain
it was or part of the British Empire it
was kind of this thing that the European
powers didn't you know didn't view is
that relative but now it was the richest
country in the world and then you
fast-forward to 1898 and it starts to
essentially become a bit of an empire
you know until this time the United
States kind of kept to itself it wasn't
really interested in controlling other
nations or other people but in an 1898
you had this constant until 1898 Cuba
was a Spanish colony and there had been
money revolts trying against the Spanish
by the Cubans and the United States or
the Americans were fairly sympathetic to
the Cubans at after all you know here's
another country in the New World again
kind of revolt against a European power
and the Spanish were pretty infamous for
cracking down pretty hard
and so in 1898 the during while there
was a revolt against the Spanish the
United States sent some sent some sent
some ships over to Havana Harbor
essentially to protect American
interests and this might this might
resonate a little bit relative to maybe
the the the mexican-american war that we
kind of send things close to another
country to kind of protect our interests
and make sure nothing crazy happens and
then while in Savannah Harbor while in
that Savannah while in Havana Harbor you
have a battleship a u.s. battleship
called the main the main that explodes
and sinks and this is an actual picture
of it this is fun because we're entering
the point in history where pictures
start to become relevant although even
in the even in the mid 1860s you had
pictures that's a picture of Abraham
Lincoln the main gets sunk the people
who want to declare war on Spain say hey
Spain must have blown up the main
although this is completely it's still a
complete mystery on what was the actual
cause some people say it was just a
random explosion there's even conspiracy
theorists who believe that the United
States did it to itself intentionally to
justify entering the war while some say
you know Spain did it for whatever
reason it didn't like the it didn't like
this this this American fleet in Havana
Harbor but regardless to say after this
happened it allowed it made the American
public angry the American government
angry and they declared war on Spain and
it was actually a very short-lived war
they won pretty handedly and the big
takeaway from the spanish-american war
is that the United States essentially
became an empire it started to have
control of other countries and in
particular it had temporary control of
Cuba but it also because it won it got
control of Guam which is right over
there and it still has control of it
still has control of Guam it also got
control of the Philippines from Spain
and it maintained control of the
Philippines until the end of World War
two and it had got control of Puerto
Rico which is still part of the United
States it's not an official state but it
is United States territory so at this
point the United States becomes becomes
an empire and then you fast-forward to
1914 war breaks out in Europe I need to
do a whole series of videos on world war
on World War one but war breaks out in
Europe particularly the the kind of the
two strongest powers that are really at
each other at this time period are the
British Empire the British Empire and
Germany and you have this situation
where United States is trying its
hardest to stay neutral and they're
obviously the American people were
predominantly of English descent who
it's an english-speaking country so
there were some sympathies for for for
the British Empire for Great Britain but
you had this but they but they wanted to
stay neutral but you what you had
happening is that the British had a
blockade of the Germans they were really
kind of had a stranglehold and the
Germans wanted to have a blockade of the
British because this you know the
British were Great Britain was an island
especially well it was an island it
could it could really maybe win the war
if it could somehow strangle the island
if it could blockade the island but
unfortunately for Germany it did not
have as strong of a navy so you get
close to 1917 actually 1915 1916 1917
Germany starts to get desperate so it
sends its submarines into Atlantic they
say well if we can't blockade Great
Britain at least maybe we can start we
can start harassing ships or even
blowing
ships that are trying to trade with
Great Britain and that'll make people
afraid to - it'll essentially be the
equivalent of a blockade and at first
Germany does some minor things but as
the war goes on it gets more and more
desperate it gets more and more
desperate and it starts it starts TAC
attacking civilian ships cruise liners
Americans start dying because German
u-boats are just willy-nilly just shoot
it just essentially torpedoing ships so
the US doesn't tolerate it anymore
enters the war in 1917 Germany didn't
take the United States that seriously up
to that point but it learned and will do
a whole series of videos on this that it
should have and then you fast-forward to
1918 and the United States was
definitely one of you know the British
were doing all right but the United
States really turned the tide no one
really expected how large of a power
they had essentially gotten involved in
the war and then you fast-forward to
1918 in the war the war ends and the
real takeaway of this I mean there's
there's a bunch of these and we'll talk
more about this in depth in future
videos is that it ended some of the the
nations that that were on the losing end
Austrian hungry no longer became what
was the nation at least in this form the
Ottoman Empire no longer was a nation in
this form and as we will learn later
that we essentially there were huge
reparations by the victors on Germany
and that to a large degree may have led
to World War two but we won't talk in
depth about that right now the other
things that started to happen at this
point in 1920 you have the 18th and the
19th amendments being passed the 18th
enacted prohibition we're all of a
sudden you you made you made alcohol
illegal in the United States and you
know the irony of it is that's when you
have all of these movies about these
bootleggers and you have this whole
crime scene that develops around illegal
alcohol but at the same time the 19th
amendment was a little maybe a little
less controversial and in the 19th
amendment it gave it finally gave
finally gave women women the right to
vote right to vote and one of the one of
the arguments that against having women
the right to vote before this time was
hey you know only men are
fighting for the country only they have
the right to vote only they can be
soldiers but during World War one and
this happened not just in the US this
happened worldwide in World War one that
because so many men were fighting that
women really had to take up the slack
domestically and they essentially were a
big part of the war effort in terms of
just working at the factories and
producing things and so that was
probably one of the big things that on a
kind of a global basis all of a sudden
women started to get the right women
started to get the right to vote and
also at this period you have in the
1920s you have another post-war post-war
economic boom that really develops into
a post-war economic bubble all the way
until 1929 and then you have the stock
market crash and then I think some of us
know that after that period the Great
Depression ensues and that takes us and
the Great Depression continues and this
was a global Great Depression and it
continues all the way to the u.s. entry
in World War two and I'll leave you
there